clic clic waouh tu fais ip à bien le
clic merci abonne toi ça lui robert ça
va oui qu'est ce que tu manges la fée du
pop corn variable dégueulasse sont fous
partout
non non c'est mes dents et dont on
attend que l on attendre que palais que
le dentiste
non j'y vais jamais je déteste ça ouais
mais tu es au courant quand même que
c'est hyper important d'avoir des bonnes
dans la mer sont bonnes mais dont elles
sont même super bonne voie ça va être
compliqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous vous souvenez fait il ya quelques
temps maintenant je m'étais lancé dans
un projet personnel un peu particulier
j'ai décidé cette fois de se faire
refaire les dents ça m'a donné
l'occasion de vous expliquer les choses
à faire et à ne pas faire quand on se
casse les dents
le moment est venu de vous expliquer les
choses à faire et à ne pas faire quand
on ne se casse pas les dents parce que
ça arrive quand même plus souvent bon en
gros le moment est venu de vous
expliquer pourquoi c'est important de
prendre soin de ses dents pour eux et
non alors attendez fait pas les malins
je vous entends d'ici ça va c'est déjà
tout ça vous savez mais est ce que vous
le faites déjà et puis surtout est ce
que vous savez vraiment pourquoi c'est
important
ah oui parce que le premier truc qui
vous vient à l'esprit c'est sûrement que
prendre soin de ses dents c'est
important pour éviter mal d'avoir mal
aux dents d'avoir les dents jaunes et
depuis du bec et vu qu'en ce moment on
porte toutes et tous des masques le
dernier point c'est sûrement celui
auquel vous avez pensé en premier
est-ce que de prise de conscience de soi
même un peu brutale comme ça bref tout
ça c'est pas faux même si pour la
couleur des dents et la laine c'est pas
juste une histoire d'hygiène bo on
s'égare donc oui tout ça c'est vrai mais
ça va plus loin que ça beaucoup plus
loin
dès lors des chaussées décarie pas
soigner des infections qui font pas
forcément mal donc on sait pas forcément
qu'on les a ça peut avoir des
répercussions sur d'autres organes et
même parfois sur des organes vitaux
bon tout ça est ce qu'on va faire on va
passer en revue 8 vraies bonnes raisons
de bien vous occuper de vos dents et
vous allez voir que oui ça peut vous
sauver
ça tombe plutôt bien parce que vu que
c'est le titre de la vidéo vous est
sûrement là pour ça allez un petit tour
d'horizon des problèmes qu'on peut
éviter quand on a des bonnes dents parce
qu'avoir des mauvaises dans c'est pas
mauvais que pour les dents les problèmes
cardiovasculaires et ouais avoir des
bonnes dents c'est bon pour le coeur et
les vaisseaux
cardio le coeur vasculaires les
vaisseaux vous l'aviez enfin avoir des
mauvaises dans ses mauvais pour le coeur
et pour les vaisseaux mais on va rester
sur la formulation positive si vous
voulez et même si vous voulez pas de
toute façon parce que hein je vous
entends pas là et 2 je suis quand même
chez moi
l'un des principaux problèmes quand on
prend ça bouge pour un terrain vague
quand on néglige son hygiène
bucco-dentaire comme on dit en jargon
c'est les bactéries et oui on a
plusieurs milliards de bactéries dans la
bouche
on sait pas combien précisément parce
que ces tout-petits et puis ça bouge
tout le temps donc c'est pas facile de
les compter mais il y en a plus de 700
espèces différentes
on estime qu' à plus de bactéries là
dedans qui a d'êtres humains sur terre
donc ça fait du monde ma venue
jacqueline chiffres parmi ces bactéries
y en a plein qui sont très utiles pour
notre organisme
mais elles peuvent aussi causer des
infections au niveau du parodonte par
exemple le parodonte c'est tous les
tissus qui a autour des dans les eaux
les gencives les nerfs les vaisseaux et
c est bien tout ça ça peut s'infecter
et c'est là que ça se gâte d'abord parce
que ces bactéries elles peuvent passer
dans la circulation sanguine est allé se
fixer sur d'autres organes comme le
coeur les poumons ou les reins par
exemple et ensuite parce qu'elles
peuvent provoquer une inflammation au
niveau des vaisseaux qui peut finir par
se rétrécir voir ce boucher et ça c'est
embêtant quand on parle des vaisseaux
qui les irriguent le coeur par exemple
en mettant étant un euphémisme
les avc exactement pour les mêmes
raisons que celles dont on vient de
parler avoir une mauvaise hygiène
bucco-dentaire ça augmente les risques
de faire un avc en gros infections
inflammation des artères vaisseau qui se
bouche
sauf que là si les vaisseaux qui se
bougent c'est pas ceux du pirine le
coeur mais ce qui irriguent le cerveau
on a littéralement un accident
vasculaire cérébral c'est à dire 1 n'a
baissé
j'en ai déjà parlé dans une vidéo
n'hésitez pas retourné et j'étais un
petit coup d'oeil je vous mets le lien
dans la description des douleurs
musculaires et articulaires
toujours au rayon mauvaise hygiène
bucco-dentaire égale infections et bien
la répercussion à laquelle on s'attend
pas les problèmes au niveau des muscles
et des articulations une parodontite une
infection est une inflammation du
parodonte nous sommait ça peut avoir des
répercussions sur des muscles ou sur des
tendons déjà fragilisée et du coup ça
peut provoquer des douleurs musculaires
voir des tendinites
il ya même des chercheurs qui ont étudié
le lien entre les parodontites et la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde dans la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde
c'est une maladie inflammatoire des
articulations et ils en ont trouvé un de
liens évidemment le diabète
alors attention on développe pas un
diabète parce qu'on a une mauvaise
hygiène bucco-dentaire et si on a déjà
le diamètre par contre ça peut aggraver
les choses
une infection ça peut perturber la
régulation de la glycémie
c'est à dire du taux de sucre dans le
sang ça c'est valable pour tout le monde
mais si on est diabétique ça peut
déséquilibrer la maladie et du coup ça
explose à toutes les complications qui
vont avec et comme le diabète il peut
lui-même provoqué des problèmes du
caudan terre parce que quand on a du
diabète on à la salive plus sucré et
qu'on est plus sensible aux infections à
c'est le serpent qui se mord oui il ya
des mots que j'évite d'employés
maintenant parce que j'ai pas rendu de
démonétiser à chaque fois bref vous avez
l'idée le diabète c'est une double bonne
raison de prendre soin de ses dents le
cancer
oui carrément le cancer certains cancers
de la sphère digestive pour être précis
oui je sais ça peut être difficile à
croire
et en vérité on sait pas exactement par
quel mécanisme on peut en arriver là
mais il ya plusieurs études qui vont
dans ce sens
celle des chercheurs de l'université de
belfast déjà qui suggère qu'une mauvaise
hygiène bucco dentaire peut augmenter de
75% le risque de développer une forme de
cancer du foie
le carcinome hépatocellulaire et une
autre menée dans un centre de
cancérologie à new york qui a conclu que
la présence de certaines bactéries qu'on
retrouve dans les parodontites augmente
significativement le risque de cancer de
l'oesophage
encore une fois à ce stade on sait pas
encore précisément comment ça marche
mais l' influence des infections
parodontale a été aussi évoquée dans
d'autres formes de cancer
et puis un autre truc par rapport au
traitement des cancers
cette fois en k2 chimiothérapie comme ça
affaiblit le système immunitaire
avant de commencer on cherche à éliminer
toutes les sources d'infection potentiel
pour éviter les ennuis
donc on va regarder l'état des dents par
exemple et dans certains cas il faut
arracher celles qui sont pas saines
donc pour les gens qui en ont beaucoup
en mauvais état on en arrache plein et
du coup ça complique encore plus une
situation qui est déjà pas très simple à
laval un accouchement prématuré
là c'est pareil le mécanisme est pas
complètement connu et les études menées
sur le sujet sont parfois
contradictoires certains montrent une
augmentation du risque d'accouchement
prématuré en lien aux infections
dentaires d'autres concluent que les
soins dentaires ne font pas
meaney et le risque bref le lien reste à
consolider mais il a été évoqué donc
sachez le des troubles de l'érection
une mauvaise hygiène bucco-dentaire nuit
aux élections attention qu'on soit bien
clair c'est l'hygiène bucco-dentaire de
la personne qui possède le pénis
concernés qui est en cause pas celle de
son ou sa partenaire
oui évidemment sauf si son partenaire
s'est lui même commencez pas à m'envoyer
parce que ça va être compliqué là on
parle d'une étude qui a mis en évidence
le fait que 73 % des personnes qui ont
un trouble de l'érection ont aussi une
parodontite chronique donc le lien de
causalité reste à prouver mais les
chercheurs ont conclu que ce problème
infectieux en particulier pouvait être
un facteur de risque de dysfonction
érectile vous faites comme vous voulez
mais dans le doute en petits dés tarf
rage ça mange pas tant d'autres trucs
vous avez compris une mauvaise hygiène
bucco-dentaire ça expose à des
infections et à des inflammations
parfois chronique au niveau des dents
mais surtout du parodonte on s'en rend
pas toujours compte donc on s'inquiète
pas ou alors on s'en rend compte mais on
laisse traîner ce qui est jamais une
bonne idée et ses problèmes il reste pas
caché au fond de notre bouche ils ont
tendance à aller se balader et allait
causer d'autres problèmes plus sérieux
ailleurs il ya tout ce dont on vient de
parler mais ils sont aussi suspectés de
provoquer de la fatigue des troubles du
sommeil d'aggraver des problèmes de
dénutrition de provoquer des douleurs au
niveau du dos des dépressions
d'augmenter le risque de démence chez
les personnes âgées etc
ça fait pas mal de bonnes raisons de
prendre fonction alors prendre soin de
ses dents ça veut dire quoi prendre soin
de ses dents ça veut dire se brosser les
dents plusieurs fois par jour évidemment
mais ça veut dire aussi à les faire
vérifier régulièrement que tout va bien
chez le dentiste
même si on n'a pas l'impression qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va pas voilà donc oui
je sais il ya plein de raisons qui font
que les gens ne vont pas assez souvent
chez le dentiste
la peur est bien là j'espère que je vous
ai donné des bonnes raisons d'y aller
plus régulièrement voilà la dtcc fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous prenez soin de vos
dents et prenez soin des autres et
prenez soin des dents des autres
non sûrement pas en tout cas mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]